well when it's time to line up packers
coaching candidates here's a name not to
put on the list a twitter user asked hey
tony dungy want to come coach the
packers
ed19 aka eric dungey says no interest
per anonymous source that's coach
zunji's son coach dunty chimes in you
must have a pretty good source because
you're dead on so no tony dungy coaching
the green bay packers but who will coach
the packers we decided to do a draft of
the ideal candidates to become the next
coach of the packers and more
specifically the next coach of aaron
rodgers peter king you get the honors
heads or tails
i'm going to take heads mike
i wish chris sims was so succinct in his
selection of a coin and its heads peter
gets the first choice peter you're up
i mean i hate to take the 800 pound
gorilla even though he probably weighs
206 pounds soaking wet but i'll take
josh mcdaniels
um the offensive coordinator the new
england patriots i think he's going to
get a lot of action this off season and
i think it could come down to just a
total guess a fight between cleveland
and green bay to be able to take him
away from
the new england patriots with absolutely
unequivocally no guarantee that he will
go he loves coaching tom brady he loves
working with bill belichick he loves
being an employee of robert kraft but if
you give me my first choice i'll take
josh mcdaniels all right i'm going to
press pause on the draft process because
i have to put this question to you peter
between the packers and the browns if
you're josh mcdaniels or anyone which
job is more attractive to you
i'd probably right now take cleveland
um
they have a better base of talent and
they have a quarterback who's
11 years younger
who by the way josh mcdaniels loves
and we put that question out there
yesterday the final results 8 970 votes
52 percent said browns 48 percent
said packers and just think of how
laughable that proposition would have
been a year ago that someone would view
yeah
better coaching destination than the
green bay packers all right first pick
for me and i've been on the record with
this one and i hope the green bay
packers do it at a minimum for
entertainment value if it doesn't work
it will be fun to watch if it works it
will be another street in green bay
named after a coach and it will be bruce
arians boulevard if it comes to that
because he's the guy i think can get
through to aaron rodgers at a time when
that's what you need he shows up with a
bottle of scotch he drinks him under the
table and he says all right baby let's
get to work and i think aryans will know
exactly what to say how to say it when
to say it how to coach him up he's got
the the reputation he's got the
experience with franchise quarterbacks
this may be the guy that aaron rodgers
would be crying out for whether he
realizes it or not and i think that's
the first guy they should call he said
he only wants the browns job that's the
only job that was open and it doesn't
look like the browns want him i think
the packers should want him and the
packers should go get him
my second round pick is uh going to be
david shaw the head coach at stanford
um a couple of years ago i had a long
conversation with david shaw he said hey
it's not me you got to convince to leave
palo alto it's my wife we have the ideal
life i've got a better job than anybody
has in the nfl right now i love stanford
well no one's ever knocked on david
shaw's door and said how would you like
to be the next coach of the green bay
packers
and they could work out this deal mike
okay we realize your family loves palo
alto
but we are we're gonna help you because
you can keep your house in palo alto and
your family can live there six months a
year and you can go visit them but we
want you to be the coach of the green
bay packers i think that's a hard
choice
and a hard team to turn down if i'm
david shaw
yeah i agree with you i mean these guys
who have been in the mix and reluctant
and you never know how long the window's
going to be open if the windows open in
green bay hard to not go through it and
and you know usually when we line up the
various categories of candidates for a
coaching opening it is college coach
fired former nfl head coach assistant
coach coordinator who is rising who has
never coached before
rarely do we get into this category of
current nfl head coach with another team
we saw it with john gruden 16 years ago
we almost saw it with jim harbaugh to
the browns five years ago and i think
one of these vacancies with a franchise
quarterback is at least going to explore
the possibility of luring a coach who
currently is working for another team to
their city so my second round pick a guy
that i think could be in play in
cleveland he could be in play in dallas
if they don't make the playoffs and
maybe he'll be in play in green bay
peter you mentioned him earlier when we
talked about the lack of imagination in
green bay they don't have a sean payton
maybe they should have a sean payton
maybe the packers should call the saints
and say what would it take by way of
compensation to give us the ability to
talk to sean payton about possibly
coming to green bay and becoming the
first coach to win super bowls with two
separate teams and working with aaron
rodgers for the last five years of his
career that would be my choice you're
gonna have to give up some draft picks
and maybe some cash to get him but it
would be money well spent to get a guy
who could come in and quickly turn
around the packers one thing became
clear yesterday they have a sense of
urgency to turn this around now and i
think peyton could bring in his system
and make it work with whoever they have
coach up whatever receivers they have
undrafted guys drafted guys street free
agents whoever and turn that team around
quickly
you know what's the most interesting
thing about that mike i'll tell you in
2006
sean payton and mike mccarthy were
interviewed for the head coaching job
with the green bay packers
ted thompson decided to pick uh mike
mccarthy sean payton was heartbroken he
desperately wanted to to finish off
brett favre's career and to start
working with aaron rodgers in green bay
and the reason why your your
your uh theory is not stupid is because
a couple of years ago i believe if the
rams had gone hard after sean payton and
offered a good draft choice for him like
even a two to the saints i think they
could have made a deal
but the rams were in love with sean
mcvay they weren't really in love with
with sean payton they were having all
these seven and nine years they didn't
really know what he was anymore so they
they didn't go after it but what would
happen if the green bay packers did
offer a first-round pick
to the saints
uh would sean payton be interested
number one
and
would uh would the would would the
saints be interested
i don't know the answer to either one of
those questions but
i would be fascinated by this because
the the match of sean payton and aaron
rodgers
could be magical in green bay so
i i have no idea you saying that just
hit me out of the blue but that's what i
think
my next do we have one more pick or no
yes yes
okay my next pick is going to be zach
taylor
uh who's obviously
on sean mcvay's staff with the los
angeles rams and i i choose him for a
very specific reason
that the one thing you hear when you
talk to people around the league the one
thing they wonder is who do you think
the next sean payton is well why don't
you take the guy who's been working
under sean payton who has been in on
these brainstorming imaginative sessions
zach taylor who's been coaching jared
goff out with the rams i would give him
i would i would give him an interview
and i think i don't know that he's ready
right now mike
but i remember what dan rooney once said
to me about mike tomlin when i asked him
geez you took mike tomlin when he was
whatever 34 years old probably a year or
two too early and he goes well by the
time we're ready to make our next
coaching change
whenever that would be 10 or 15 years
down the road mike tomlin is going to be
long long gone so if you want to if you
like the guy you better get him now so
if you interview zach taylor and you
like him you put a good support system
around him you go with zach taylor
i like that idea and i like that fact
that everybody's going to be looking for
the next sean mcvay and that's going to
continue until somebody finds someone
that they think is the next sean mcveigh
and he's a disaster then they're going
to be like ah maybe we should quit
searching so desperately for the next
sean mcveigh there'll be some other
trend that they follow and maybe that
other trend will continue this idea of
tracking down current head coaches with
other nfl teams if you thought the last
one wasn't stupid peter you may think
this one is stupid but here hear me out
hear me out
bring andy reed home to end his career
with the green bay packers he started
his nfl coaching career in 1992 on mike
holmgren's staff he was there through 98
when he surprisingly became the coach of
the eagles you get where you can this
year in kansas city eric b enemy takes
over as the head coach of the chiefs
next year and the chiefs pick up that
first round pick if the saints don't
want it and andy reid finishes his
coaching career just as aaron rodgers
finishes his playing career and then
they go fresh start new coach new
quarterback whenever those two are done
first of all that's not a clark hunt
thing i just don't see any way that
would happen and i don't think andy reid
wants to leave patrick mahomes he's died
and gone to heaven working with mahomes
and let's say he's got five more years
as a coach
i i think he's going to spend all five
with patrick mahomes but it's
interesting are we done or do we have
another one
i think we're done unless you want to
throw another one out there go ahead
throw another one out the only one i
want to throw out the only one i want to
throw out is john defilippo because even
though he's been tarnished this year as
a coach with the minnesota vikings the
one thing i know about john defilippo
after the job he did in philadelphia
especially with the young carson wentz
he has immense respect inside the eagles
building
as a guy who was great not good but
great in helping carson wentz kick-start
his career on the way from north dakota
state to the nfl um so i still
think that he's a fascinating prospect
even though his star has been dim this
year in minnesota
all right one more for me and you know i
would have said tony dungy but he's made
it clear he's not interested although i
think he would be a great interview
well it's either that or jeff tedford
and you know what i jeff tedford the
ship has sailed on him he was aaron
rodgers college coach i'll throw tony
dungey in there even though he said no i
remember last year we were joking around
make him come out with a big denial
today mike
well because here's why here's why you
know when when we saw that john gruden
was getting 10 million a year for 10
years and i know there's a lot of fluff
in there that at least got tony to say
hmm if somebody would offer me that
maybe i would have to change my mind so
hey it's a publicly traded company they
got plenty of money they can pay
whatever they want there's no profits
going into an owner's pocket if you want
to pay dungy 10 12 million a year you
can offer it to him and see if he
changes his mind
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports